what do you compliment your kids on
their Humanity if you're complimenting
your kids constantly on how attractive
they are you're so beautiful you're so
cute you're so handsome you're
instilling affirmation on that which is
gonna affect them when they're in their
30s 40s 50s and 60s because that's going
to be their self-worth if you're telling
them that they're remarkable because
they're getting A's in school you're
teaching them to conform to systems that
aren't real once they become 22. it
might not be the best idea eighth place
trophies bother me if your
seven-year-old loves Beyonce but when
she's running around the house singing
literally you have to put earplugs in
because it's the worst sound you've ever
heard it's probably a bad idea to tell
her she can be Beyonce one day too it's
not a bad idea to say if she puts in a
lot of work she could be better at
singing than she is today